ça
dominant le flanc sud du massif des
vosges le ballon d'alsace est le point
de départ du sentier de grande randonnée
qui relie les vosges au jura à cheval
entre l'alsace et la franche comté
il fait partie du parc naturel régional
des ballons des vosges le jr 59 nous
emmène du ballon d'alsace à baume les
messieurs
c'est dans les vastes prairies du massif
du ballon d'alsace que nous retrouvons
nos premiers compagnons de route
accompagnateur de moyenne montagne
jacques dato nous fait partager sa
philosophie et ses pensées en donner
c'est aussi donner on apprend des autres
on apprend en regardant on peut savoir
la météo ce qu'elle peut nous dire en
observant les oiseaux en observant le
comportement des animaux et des insectes
c'est tout un ensemble c'est un ensemble
à vivre petite halte à la ferme ou
grégory s'activent à rentrer ses chèvres
les petits qui sont encore sous la main
et petits qui on a dans l'ain peu dans
le désastre possible sauf ce vrai
l'effet rap à les biens situés sur les
flancs du ballon d'alsace à 750 mètres
d'altitude
la ferme auberge du littoral feld est
une affaire familiale
rae
adèle la petite dernière apporte des
soins constants aux chevreaux comme une
lutte contre leur destin tragique
jeanine marie louise et alexandra leur
réserve un sort lui succulent on est
aussi un peu et on met
un peu de verdure
on sait ainsi de sauce grand veneur
vision à café cognac
c'est un peu ce cas maison quand même si
vous refaites à l'ancienne ou en abris
notre regard que les femelles pour la
reproduction et donc les petits mâles ne
peut pas tous les gars j'ai donc dit
phosphate intel
ça me faisait mal comme à l'âge de ma
petite soeur maintenanciers faire
maintenant le cuisine au beurre dont
l'élève et on le cuisine google
reprenons notre route et qui tourne
alsace pour arriver en franche comté ce
petit groupe de randonneurs fait partie
de l'association qui s'occupe de
l'entretien et du balisage du sentier
parcourant le chemin qui mène à la
chapelle notre dame du haut ils
repeignent avec un oeil attentif
ces symboles détériorés par le temps de
couleurs rouge et blanche
il indique les sentiers de grande
randonnée
nous les accompagnons jusqu'à la
chapelle notre dame du haut situé dans
la commune de roujan
construite en 1935 la chapelle est un
élément majeur de l'art sacré
contemporain un lieu de culte imaginée
par le corbusier le travail de
l'architecte va au delà de la conception
de la chapelle comme peintre il a
également conçu et dessiné les motifs
des vitraux et de la porte d'entrée
le corbusier a voulu créer un lieu de
silence et de paix dans lequel l'art le
sacré et la nature se rejoignent en
poursuivant notre chemin sur le gr 59
nous faisons une rencontre insolite
marie dominique et jean luc inaugure un
nouveau concept de balade
je m'adresse beaucoup en famille aux
enfants pour avoir envie de faire des
efforts avoir envie d'aller au delà de
ses habitudes
donc il faut provoquer un petit un effet
de surprise donc la masse est c'est un
bon vecteur et en plus on habite dans
une zone humide les annecy plairait pas
de terrain est fragile et la maille
beaucoup plus rustique les lamas ses
caractéristiques chez lui il est il
induit la paix il est calme et il marche
doucement il est il est sensible aux
sons et eux sont très habitués aux
enfants donc il n'y a aucun souci ils
laissent pas ils ont des coussins sous
les pattes c'est pas des sabots ils sont
grands ils imposent le respect ils sont
un peu hautain donc effectivement ils
induisent le calme
fin de cette parenthèse péruvienne
direction le massif du jura
ici nous faisons halte dans une zone
naturelle remarquable le marais de
saulnot est un lieu privilégié pour
observer la faune sauvage paul flux que
j'ai accompagné de caroline mafflu
participent intensivement à la
préservation de ce biotope une fauvette
à tête noire et paul ahyi ce polyglotte
à lormont entendu le pigeon ramier le
coucou
la fauvette à tête noire la rousserolle
effarvatte dans les gens ici là la
mésange charbonnière la mésange
charbonnière
comme quoi on peut faire un inventaire
rien qu'en écoutant les chants d'oiseaux
l'abri le couvert et le restaurant voilà
ce qu'il faut à manger les insectes au
niveau de l'étang dans la roselière dans
le marais ya pas mal de d'un secteur
pour nourrir les oiseaux qu'ils ont tout
ce qu'il faut pour se plaire ou moins en
halte migratoire
suivons maintenant frédéric le frère de
paul il photographie au cours de ces
excursions les quelques 152 espèces
végétales du marais à ses côtés nous
partons à la découverte d'une plante à
la structure peu commune le tour a dont
les plans ont pratiquement 50 ans d'âge
et elle croit toujours vers le haut elle
ne s'étend pas par de ribéry job les
rhizomes sont toujours heures la râpe à
fleurs et elle continue à pousser que
son ton peuple et elle continue à régler
il planteur est devenu rare très rare
même en plaine
le sol on le sent vraiment spongieux
c'est tous les déchets de 2,38 fonction
des phrases se transformant en
tourbières carrément dans le temps et
s'en servaient pour couvrir les toits
c'était là sa remplacer les tuiles mais
autrement la fonction d'aidé phragmites
non il n'y a aucune heure maintenant ils
me servent à combler un vide c'est tout
bon elles ont le droit à la vie comme
les autres
prochaine étape la jolie ville de
villersexel cette petite cité de
caractère abrite un château classé
monument historique datant du 19e siècle
le château connu une histoire
mouvementée
aujourd'hui on peut le visiter au jeu et
être accueillis par jean pierre pothin
le maître des lieux gentil à vous d'être
venu jusqu'ici contre est longue
quel pays vous allez pouvoir
l'édifice superbe copie de style louis
xiii aurait été construit par deux
architectes prestigieux charles garnier
et gustave eiffel
certains ont même brandi il nos voisins
germains ont occupé le château et n'ont
rien pris en 1945 joie de la libération
tout a été volé depuis trente ans je me
débats je rachète les meubles je les
retrouve
je les remets à leur place et le château
que vous voyez c'est celui qui existait
il ya cent ans
le château aurait abrité de nombreux
invités célèbres montagnes l'illustrent
général lafayette et le maréchal joffre
la légende raconte que charles de gaulle
et winston churchill y aurait résidé
le château c'est la démesure c'est un
hectare de toiture c'est des longueurs
immense s'est plus particulièrement une
stature métallique de gustave eiffel qui
permet d'avoir une maison étonnamment
ouverte et très peu de murs porteurs et
si la visite vous a convaincu sachez que
vous pouvez passer la nuit dans les
lieux de nos illustres ancêtres
quittons la plaine pour arriver sur les
premières pentes du massif jurassien
le paysage change radicalement chaîne
deux plissements le jura donné naissance
un type de relief bien spécifiques
dominant les hauteurs de la vallée du
cusancin nous reprenons notre itinéraire
avec sylvie debras fondatrice et
rédactrice du magazine en vadrouille
elle parcourt chaque année près de 600
km de sentiers elle photographie et note
avec attention chaque détail de la
balade qu'elle proposera aux marcheurs
il ya des chemins balisés donc y en a
qui part de la petite chapelle
saint-hernin froid qu'on voit là quand
on grimpe on est grande quand on grimpe
le matin c'est le début de la balade on
trouve c'est très très dur de grimper là
et en fait c'est une toute petite butte
on le voit de là il ya un chemin de
crête qui est balisé par lui hervé qui
courent là tout le long de la crête et
un autre chemin de crête là qui vient de
monter vers nage mais il ya quelques
centaines de mètres de dénivelé face et
pas les ânes pas non plus
alors là c'est un bel exemple de
géologie jurassienne on est sur un
lapiaz jeunes c'est-à-dire une table de
calcaire qui en train de se fissurer de
s'entailler et puis on a des petites
cuves est comme ça là où vont pousser on
a une petite jardinière il ya une petite
plante qui pousse et c'est un récipient
ça va contenir de l'eau ça va creuser
l'eau à s'infiltrer est-ce qu'on voit la
sueur sur le sol c'est exactement la
même chose sous le sol
dire que le sous-sol de la franche comté
c'est un énorme gruyère plein de galerie
avec des sources des rivières
souterraines qui sortent toutes formes
et des montagnes de car c'est justement
ce paysage tourmenté offre le gîte à une
faune paisible les lumières les ombres
alternent dans cette région fortement
boisée composé à 70% de feu lui la forêt
recouvre presque la moitié de la franche
comté
jacques lacoste dessinateur nous fait
découvrir des endroits qu'ils inspirent
dans notre étape la plus urbaine
besançon
je
alors là nous arrivons sur la place de
la révolution les bisontins connaît
surtout son terme de la phase du marché
parce que pendant très longtemps il ya
eu les marchés sur cette place est
l'intérêt de cette place aussi
ce sont ces bâtiments alors nous avons
l'école de musique
le musée des beaux-arts et sur le fond
nous avons passé du saint-esprit et
cette superbe fontaine qui a été
déplacée puisque la place a été restauré
il ya deux ans donc c'est tout récent
assurément jacques s'est beaucoup
promené en ville dans son livre besançon
ville patrimoine
il propose des dessins au crayon presque
photographique illustrant la richesse de
la cité comtoise
dessins au crayon j'en fais depuis
toujours depuis que je suis gamin
j'adore ce à quoi je dessine toujours
des moutons le coup effectivement s'il
n'y a pas la couleur mais peu importe
justement c'est un mois de simplement
avec du noir et blanc de créer une
ambiance une lumière
une vie quoi c'est pas c'est pas triste
du tout cette fois l'illustration c'est
du dessin documentaire en fait cité
d'art et d'histoire
rien d'étonnant que la ville natale de
victor hugo figure depuis 2008 au
patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
entamons la deuxième partie de notre
périple en direction de baume les
messieurs en suivant la direction du gr
ne nous arrêtons quelques instants pour
admirer un paysage
le cirque du fer à cheval avec une
falaise de plus de 240 mètres de hauteur
l'endroit abrite la grotte des planches
respectivement guide et spéléologue jean
yves perrier et roger lutz nous offre
une occasion de pénétrer dans un monde
souterrain mystérieux et dit observer
des formations rocheuses inconnu à la
surface découverte en 1813 la grotte
porte des traces attestant du passage
des hommes durant la préhistoire
aujourd'hui encore elle n'a pas fini de
nous livrer ses secrets
si vous revenu on a eu notre période de
l'année on pourrait voir cette grotte
avec avec de l'eau beaucoup d'eau
une cascade dans le fond un on aurait le
bruit l'ambiance
ceux ci font été régulièrement parcouru
par des plongeurs dont le but est
d'explorer les galeries positifs ont
donc il se trouve derrière ceux ci
feront ces galeries actuellement connus
font environ six kilomètres de longueur
le potentiel réel de cette grotte et de
et de plus de 60 km
regardez là on voit petit pet blanc ce
qui booste un petit crustacé qui est
totalement aveugle totalement
dépigmenter et qui vit soudé et vit
uniquement sous terre parce que s'ils
sortaient bas il mourrait tout de suite
brouillet vous brûlez parler et rayons
solaires une grosse truie nous apporter
deux vaudois et grisons prisonnière au
fond d'un trou auquel elles vivent pas
dans la grotte et sont plutôt survivent
quoi on va dire donc voilà la plus belle
et la plus grande des marmites de la
grotte des planches
alors ça c'est une forme avec avec des
galettes
parce que en fait les marmites foot ya
jeté des galets et avec le courant de du
tour en mai ce galet arrive à ronger la
la paroisse est d'ailleurs on voit bien
les traces d'érosion sur tout le tour
et celle ci est particulièrement
régulière on a l'impression que ça a été
creusé par un fort est tellement c'est
tellement serré par part contre le gall
et a disparu par logiquement on devrait
retrouver au fond le galet avec les
résidus d'érosion qu'on trouve pas au
pied du cirque du fer à cheval
le lent travail de l'érosion a donné
naissance à ses valets en cul-de-sac
appelé reculer un peu plus au sud
accroché sur son rocher château chalon
est un des plus beaux villages de france
il veille sur ses vignes et dans ses
caves sommeil le précieux vin jaune jean
berthe est bondé les viticulteurs
il nous livre les secrets de fabrication
de l'or jaune du jura
là je vais procéder au contrôle d'un
flux de château-chalon ans le château
chalon certains jouent là-dessus donc on
est élaboré à partir du cépage savagnin
élevé pendant six ans au dessus alors le
punk un jaune parce que au bout de six
ans fuit un petit peu plus coloré quand
même que les maintenant classique
une fois que le château le château
chalon et ans en fugue
dans ces conditions là il ya des arômes
typiques paraissent assez vite
20 des arômes d'amandes de noisettes de
noix elles sont bien décelable en un
joli vin qui a pris un bon départ qui
n'est pas abouti encore parce qu'il faut
attendre six ans 1 mais là il était très
bien
c'est presque plein la partie off active
qui est plus la plus importante dans la
dégustation
on décèle déjà beaucoup de choses
données et voilà un flux qui est bien un
truc qui peut rester là encore cinq ans
avant d'être mise en bouteille
nous retrouvons jean dans ses vignes
le royaume du vin jaune ce sont 50 ha
baignée de soleil
donc là on a un sol assez assez pierreux
en c1 sur la c'est propice à la culture
du cépage chardonnay sur un autre
secteur pas très loin d'ici vous aurez
des terres plus marneuses beaucoup plus
adapté aux six pages sa manière
retour sur le gr 59 toujours vers le sud
nous prenons maintenant la direction de
granges sur boom
après le vin le fromage c'est la famille
poulet qui nous accueillent fromage et
de père en fils hubert à la fabrication
fabien à l'avance je pense que mon frère
que mon père allait glucagon frère
un nombre des jeux
devront compter du bourbier de l'atome
de jura qu'on fabrique ici et ceux ci
sont fabriqués sans noyau avec des
petits morceaux de leur vie et de celle
où le corps devrait avoir cru qu'on
roule encore à la main de la
cancoillotte balmont produits régionaux
et on retrouve hubert dans la cave
un expert en affinage les frotte deux
fois par semaine c'est des fromages là
qui ont un mois d'affinage
donc voilà après les plus frais ce qu'on
a fait on les frotte tous les jours
pendant une semaine alors bien salée est
ce là voilà quand les faits sont les
faits elles ou avec un peu moins de
celle après mon arrière grand père
fromage et à mon grand père donc on ne
peut pas le frère à mon père le frère
mon papa et puis un autre cousin aussi
donc on a un peu toute une famille c'est
que pendant les repas de famille on
parle de fromage dernière escale et pas
des moindres baume les messieurs les
soulèvements géologiques ont fait de ce
paysage l'un des plus riches et des plus
remarquables de franche comté au fond du
cir au pied des falaises se trouve la
cascade des tuffes
c'est dans ce cadre grandiose que didier
favre nous invite à sa table
au menu salade de truites ou savagnin
donc oui c'est assez difficile de bien
suivre les filets laisser le moins cher
le moins possible de chair sur sur les
filets
pour avoir quelque chose de plus il est
possible qu'ils soient assez présentable
j'utilise principalement des truites
blanche qui est l'origine détruire c'est
pas les
les vrais tweets sont blanches n'est pas
ce mot n'est contrairement à ce qu'on
peut trouver souvent et c'est un produit
vraiment d'ici quoi puis en plus gênés
rivière jusqu'au bout de mon jardin qui
est en bas de ma cuisine donc voilà le
beurre vient de la fromagerie de granges
sur boom qui est juste au dessus tout
les fromages on utilise aussi sur le
restaurant viennent bien disent ils
les commandes du côté chair
bien les saisir au départ sur un puck
est légèrement noisette et je vais les
retourner que tel soit à peine coloris
et devant on va finir vraiment cuisson
très basses températures qui restent
moroses à l'intérieur
pour remonter un petit peu le goût la
vinaigrette de noix justement une petite
patte de noix que je mets sous le filet
tweet show justement un cas porte un
petit goût sympathique à la truite un
petit peu
le savagnin selon fille détruites
apporter un petit goût
elle reste sous
mais on est bien
avec une petite vinaigrette
quelques petits trucs
donc encore tier de poser sur la salade
voilà votre petite salade de truites à
la vinaigrette de noix voilà
nous terminons notre périple devant
l'abbaye de baume les messieurs nicher
là depuis le 9e siècle elle est la
destination finale de notre randonnée un
voyage de 180 km trait d'union entre
deux massifs les vosges et le jura